311 netz bekommen beim ein videokünstler
reihenfolge zieht sehr visionen klein zu
mittwoch gedacht ich hoffe euch nicht
gut und gibt auch wunderbar wir sind
nämlich hier auch der wunderschönen
insel fort fun to maine spanien also das
ist fast in afrika würden
und ja wir haben ja echt ein gutes
projekt am start und führte ein drittel
wegen bei also meiner mode korrekte und
da kommt nämlich auch am 21 nächsten
montag seine neue kollektion und nummer
sagen und hier entsteht auch ein anderes
projekt und zwar drehen wir ein echtes
video dazu aber später noch mehr ich
habe mir gedacht wenn wir hier so eine
schöne man kann ja eigentlich schon
sagen fast so es ist auf jeden fall ein
sehr großes haus in spanien immer
belange also wir haben ja echt nen ist
wirklich wirklich schöne finca und ich
wünsche euch etwas zeigen ihr kennt mich
ja ich habe am anfang nie lange bei mir
sofort an und zwar ganz planmäßig wir
sind jetzt erstmals anfang mit dem
unspannenden an und damit ihr nicht so
spannend
das ist hier der wohnbereich hier hängen
wir abends manchmal zusammen und trinken
das eine oder andere glas abgeschottet
genau also schritt auf jeden fall echt
cool eingerichtet hier ist ein kleiner
worauf ich meine das ist einmal der user
hinter der kamera
conard ist dabei welche zu 50 gedacht
und hier können sogar acht leuten aber
sie ist auf jeden fall die küche sehr
[Musik]
aufgeräumt
ich musste meinen tag bestimmt deutsche
zwischen richtig geil also meistens
diese schönen die gefällten alle seine
küche köpfchen sondern auch echte
vorstellen
und jetzt gibt es glaube ich gleich
erstmal die welt gemacht
[Musik]
mega cool also ist das thema von felix
weiß gar nicht ob dieser getränkemarkt
einfach nicht liegt auch keine frage
ich muss mal gucken was machst du hier
für lange zeit waren als ich sagt ihm
angenommen zu erhält ist aber auch nicht
so besonders die meisten hat und zwar
ist mein bart mal gemacht
andere genießen weil ich gehen einen
bart und nehme ein paar ja und hier
schlafen wenn man müde ist einfach so
dass jetzt weiter geht allmorgendlich
einen leichten sonnenbrand
der klassiker wie gesagt wir machen hier
im video und weiter als immer vielleicht
am kamera draufhalten und begrüßen also
keine location hier vor allem um abends
bisschen sich zu entspannen
sie trocknet aus viele der leute kennt
ja wahrscheinlich aus schauen also
zumindest von letzten zwei wir haben
videos sorgen macht dass mark ii
und die ist auch dabei und zwar brauchen
natürlich auch mädchen in den videos und
etwas mitbekommen und das hier ist der
fähre
der liegt eigentlich egal weil ich muss
ehrlich egal wenn ich rauskomme der
liegt hier arbeitet klar
und ja das ist unser wunderschöner
[Musik]
kurzschlussreaktion
[Applaus]
also ich muss sagen der tour ist echt
mega geil wenn man bis man so diese
farbe ankunft ich kann nicht sagen dass
sich der ton in dem ich je schwimmbad
[Applaus]
anlaufen
war gut
nach oben aber ich wollte eigentlich
oben schlafen aber da habe ich gesagt
okay so lieb wie immer bei mir scheint
dieses ding ist tot
wir sind tot stellt euch mal vor dieses
dingen krabbelt euch nacht über den kopf
oder so
[Musik]
ja okay dann würde ich sagen
wiederholt habe ich noch irgendwas
vergessen
und genau wie diese untereinander
harmonieren weil die streiten zimmer und
zweitens ist wirklich richtig kraft und
die kleine verliert immer und ja echt
angst dass man die einer braucht aber
[Musik]
das mögen die mag ich echt gerne habe
ich schon sehr entfernt locken und die
andere marke
sie kann bleiben wo der pfeffer wächst
das war es eigentlich ihr könnt ja wenig
kommentar schreiben wir dafür findet und
ob sie auch schon auf vollen touren was
interessiert mich noch nach oben da
steckt man als letzte instanz und wir
sehen uns am sonntag wieder sonntag
kommt ein neues cooles video haut ein